hey so um i was telling you this before
before
the cameras came on like bro like i feel
like
you've had a crazy few years but
you're one of the biggest factors when
it comes to
the west coast [ __ ] but i feel like you
still don't necessarily get
the recognition the recognition that you
probably deserve i think
now i know like racist buyership i think
it's a lot of it's just it's new to
people like i'm asian you know what i'm
saying
like i still got work to do i still got
um doors to knock down and [ __ ]
i just feel like that that plays a big
part cause i see a lot of [ __ ]
saying you know i'm the biggest
independent artist
out here in la who does these numbers or
i'm the
who does these numbers independent or
who does this does that when really i
look at my [ __ ] and i look at their [ __ ]
no no competition [ __ ] but rap is
competitive but it's like
i do these numbers and my name don't get
mentioned you know what i'm saying
like yo i've i've had conversations with
the guys at empire you're like
one of the biggest artists as far as
just revenue
at the at empire they say i stream very
well i [ __ ] with empire for life for
sure
yeah you stream very well those yo it's
crazy because
another guy like you know someone you've
got a great relationship with is mozzie
um who's shared an empire statement
what is your biggest statement you've
gotten do you
not to be in your pocket like you know
you get your monthly empire
you know uh what i get like oh never
like money wise yeah like that's like
the biggest month you've had for
like like off your music [ __ ]
my whole my whole my whole my whole life
for sure
nah but i touch i touch a lot of money
with empire you know what i'm saying i
touch
i touch a lot of money with empire but
let's talk about the first time i seen
some [ __ ]
so the first time i seen some [ __ ] i was
eating
i think i was i was i was still hustling
too i'm over here paying for all my
music [ __ ] trying to make ends meet
paying for that apartment in downtown
because i just had my son
so he's two now that's about two years
ago yeah this is like when mandel
dropped you know what i'm saying
and then um i get a call from nema i was
eating that food at a full restaurant
with my girl
and i'm like and i'm i'm over before i
got that call from nina i'm talking to
homes like we need to make this place
make this place all right
or you know do little [ __ ] to hustle
right and then i get the call from nema
you're like man how come you didn't tell
me that we haven't been paying you it's
just been stacking up and stacking up
and i was just like what the [ __ ] and
then he just you know it was um he's
like yeah i'm gonna send
do you want to check or i'm gonna send
it to your account like i'm sending some
accounts like how much is he's like
57 000 or something like but it was just
that's like the first
big number you know what i'm saying [ __ ]
and i was just like hell yeah i was like
me i need that run that
yeah my places didn't go through like 10
minutes ago right
like i'm over here send up plays yeah
but i got more
more from more from them for sure um you
know after that but
it started getting bigger and bigger but
i remember that was the first like
chunky
like that was just no that was the first
check ever you know what i'm saying wow
yeah that's a hell of a first rap chat
yeah like what the [ __ ]